nous sommes le 1er juillet 2015 bonsoir
merci de nous rejoindre sur téléphiles
soixante dix huit dans ce journal il
sera notamment question de météo le
département des yvelines est toujours en
vigilance orange en raison de la vague
de chaleur caniculaire provenant du
maghreb via l'espagne en 2003 durant
l'été la france a connu une canicule
exceptionnelle et qui a entraîné une
surmortalité estimée entre 15000 et
20000 décès la vigilance est donc
aujourd'hui devises ils étaient une
trentaine à se mobiliser hier soir
clayes-sous-bois pour protester contre
deux projets de la mairie à la fermeture
du centre de loisirs des prières et le
déplacement de la halle du marché et
puis elle alstom open de france de golf
était but demeure jeudi à 50 ans will
beall 99e édition de l'événement nous en
parlons avec le directeur du site
invité du journal nous verrons aussi
côté compétition les ambitions du nord
irlandais graeme mcdowell qui va tenter
de réaliser un triplé depuis ce matin de
nouvelles règles s'appliquent pour les
automobilistes l'oreillette est ainsi
paix mis au volant et il pourrait vous
en coûter jusqu'à 135 euros et 3 points
forces de l'ordre autre changement le
taux d'alcool par litre de sang
pour les jeunes conducteurs de 0,5 à 0,2
g il est aussi interdit dorénavant de se
maquiller ou de manger même aux feux
rouges
que pensez vous de ces nouvelles mesures
en vigueur depuis maintenant le début de
la journée c'est notre question du jour
je suis d'accord c'est à dire c'est à
dire qu'il ya plein de l'accident qui
sont dus à ça et donc
je pense que les gens seront plus
inattentif téléphone voilà on n'a pas le
choix à nos éleveurs
en fait les camions il n'est pas occupé
de nipissing m n'est rien du tout on est
obligé appelé les clients
une demi-heure avant d'écouter ça
devient de plus en plus sévères pour
certaines choses je pense c'était
indispensable
les oreillettes des choses comme ça si
quelqu'un klaxons c'est vraiment
catastrophique mais on pousse le bouchon
un peu trop loin je pense c'est un peu
c'est un peu dur quand même hein parce
que je veux dire on n'est pas des bébés
est toujours tout nous dire ce qu'on a à
faire et tout quand on aime un stop on
n'a pas le droit de boire donc je pense
qu'on instaure grosse carrière
je pense qu'on ne devrait pas avoir
besoin de légiférer pour ça voilà que ça
participe du bon sens et plus de
l'éducation c'est vrai que c'est
important
voilà des traces qu'on fait quand on
conduit mais je pense pas qu'on ait
besoin de légiférer pour ça attention à
ces nouvelles interdictions en tout cas
40 départements sont placés en vigilance
orange canicule par météo france
toujours les communes s'organisent pour
faire face à cette vague de chaleur qui
reste exceptionnel
exemple à montigny le bretonneux des
mesures viennent renforcer le dispositif
déjà existant et et solidarité instaurée
chaque année pour les personnes âgées et
fragilisées yolaine autorisé elodie
moines 9h ce matin sur le secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines julien aux
chaînes les livraisons de repas aux
personnes âgées
je ferai toujours hybrid ont repéré la
bouteille d'eau dans le cadre du
dispositif de prévention canicule de
montigny le bretonneux la bouteille
d'eau s'est ajoutée à chaque panier
repas depuis lundi pour éviter tout
malaise et qu'ils soient bien hydratée
voilà ce qui longtemps défaillante et
ans aussi a pas trop s'hydrater donc au
moins on préfère prévenir que guérir
prévenir c'est tout l'enjeu du
dispositif mis en place par la ville
comme chaque année un registre nominatif
recense environ 200 personnes âgées ou
fragilisées
les appels ont démarré hier donc nous
les appelons pour savoir si elles sont
au courant si elles prennent les bonnes
décisions de savoir qu'il faut qu'elles
boivent très régulièrement donc on
vérifie tout ça si elles sont ils ont
entouré par de la famille par des amis
des voisins et puis une fois que nous
avons fait ça effectivement s'il ya des
personnes
on sent qu effectivement il ya une
certaine fragiles et plus fort nous
pouvons aller par l'intermédiaire
d'agents de la ville allait leur portée
disons de l'eau est vérifiée en même
temps leur état en cas de problème les
visiteurs interagissent ensuite avec la
coordination gérontologique locale mais
la canicule de 2003 semble avoir laissé
des traces
les personnes âgées restent pour la
plupart vigilante beaucoup sur très très
au courant je crois que ce qui s'était
passé il ya quelques années a fait
qu'effectivement tout le monde est quand
même relativement sensibiliser et je
pense que pour le moment sur montigné
nous avons plutôt des réactions
positives ou les gens disent oui vous
inquiétez pas je bois je fais attention
je ferme mes volets pas de problème
dispositif reste en place jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine au moins et sera peut être
prolongée si la chaleur persiste la
vague de chaleur qui s'abat sur toute la
france quasiment cette semaine un pacte
plus particulièrement certains corps de
métiers comme celui de la restauration
travailler au soleil pour servir en
terrasse ou encore en cuisine à côté des
plaques de cuisson tous doivent
s'adapter à ces températures élevées
william l
que l'on soit assis en terrasse au
soleil ou à l'ombre d'un parasol
difficile de ne pas souffrir de la vague
de chaleur qui s'installe sur le pays
cette semaine
pour les clients comme pour les employés
pas d'autre solution que de s'adapter
il ya deux trois soleil la terrasse et
complète les gens veulent pas les
intérieurs préfère aller dehors c'est un
peu étouffant c'est un peu on s'épuise
beaucoup plus vite on essaie de se
rafraîchir en allant dans les chambres
froides sont rafraîchies un petit peu on
boit beaucoup d'eau servir les clients
s'est passé sa journée de bon entre la
salle et la cuisine à subir des
différences de température alors pendant
cette semaine de canicule patron
redouble d'attention en maternant un peu
plus ses employés il faut faire
attention d'être bien près pour éviter
les faux geste il faut faire attention
que le personnel s'hydratent bien donc
il faut les obliger constamment avoir de
l'eau parce que on est au service du
client donc un petit peu plus dynamique
quelqu'un d' assis sur son fauteuil et
voilà donc voilà les premières règles et
puis bien faire attention quoi ne pas
faire trop de deux pas et c'est enfin de
le métier normalement mais on en est
encore un peu plus attentif petit tour
en cuisine où d'ordinaire la température
est déjà très élevé aujourd'hui il vaut
mieux préparer des salades que de
travailler au crime yves qui lui était
aux choses mehdi a vécu plus fortement
la chaleur que moi nous au froid ans
meurt on se maintient tranquillement
voilà on n'a pas le la salamandre la
halle sur la gueule et le piano qui
chauffe mécontents à la chambre fois
c'est certain mais la petite astuce est
quand même que tout le personnel sa
bouteille d'eau avec des températures
qui vont signer entre 32 et 38 degrés
tout au long de la semaine
la meilleure solution pour ces
travailleurs restent de boire de l'eau
le plus souvent possible
comme les clients on se désaltère on
voit beaucoup d'eau je bois beaucoup
d'eau et je me repose énormément
on a pris une grande salade chacune
crudités am ton
saumon fumé non ce n'est peut-être pas
si frais que ça mais vous au mas doit on
frêche
voilà et malgré la chaleur mardi soir
plus d'une centaine de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois ce collectif de
citoyens souhaité montrer son opposition
à deux projets la future fermeture du
centre de loisirs des bruyères et le
déplacement également de la halle du
marché floral parfait mélanie poquet
alto béton c'est le message de ces
citoyens réunis devant la mairie pour le
conseil municipal
ils se posent à la façon dont va être
rénovée la halle du marché mais en
priorité à l'abandon du projet de
réhabilitation du centre de loisirs des
bruyères beaucoup de colère on voudrait
conserver ses deux coeurs de villages
quoi on comprend il faut faire évoluer
une commune c'est hyper important mais
on n'est pas très contents parce que
réellement dans sa campagne elle avait
dit qu elle préserverait ces deux points
importants des claies hélas et les deux
qu'elle nous fait exploser en miettes
selon les manifestants les bruyères
appartiennent au patrimoine de la ville
ils ne veulent pas avoir déplacé leurs
enfants ailleurs notamment pendant les
vacances
un mécontentement dû à une mauvaise
information et une incompréhension
estime manière la concertation ce n'est
pas de dire ça ferait quand tout est
fini voilà ce que nous allons faire
c'est de demander d'abord aux gens ce
qu'ils souhaitent
et à ce moment là on est le projet aux
places
je sais grâce tic de nos dotations et
une augmentation énorme exponentielle de
nos péréquation financière
donc nous devons faire des recherches de
mutualisation des équipements
donc nous avions effectivement un projet
d'un centre de loisirs un coût d'environ
5 millions sur le terrain du bayer ce
projet est modifiée c'est à dire qu'il
aura pu vivre hier nous nous le stockons
les deux projets devraient être
réalisées en 2010 est des explications
qui n'ont pas satisfait le collectif de
citoyens présents dans le conseil
municipal déterminer le collectif a déjà
réuni plus de 1500 signatures dans une
pétition pour soutenir sa peau on passe
à l'invité de ce 1er juillet paulien
d'armitage merveille en plateau vous
êtes le directeur du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en poste
depuis septembre dernier
oui quelques jours vous allez donc vivre
votre premier open de france open de
golf et dans quelques heures ce sera une
première pour vous un moment particulier
vous vous y préparer depuis votre
arrivée en septembre
oui oui c'est sympa c'est 1,52 vous très
important qu'on peut imaginer dans une
année heureusement il ya une bonne
équipe qui existe déjà chez seat qui en
a vécu beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
moi j'ai hâte d'y être demain pour
attaquer c'est vrai c'est en préparation
quand on arrive au moment venu on se
demande ce qu'on va faire exactement
parce qu'il ya toute une équipe
d'organisation beaucoup de préparation
il faut préparer le green
oui si ce chat il faut le dire sur tout
le terrain
la maintenance la tendance la
préparation du terrain qui est la partie
cruciale parce que si si on a la chance
d'avoir cet open c'est parce que le
parcours et les reconnu et connu et tout
le monde a envie de la jouer il faut
qu'il soit dans le meilleur état c qui
est difficile cette année avec la météo
et comment vous faites justement pour
maintenir le green suffisamment vers ben
on arrose on fait très attention à ce
qu'on fait et évidemment on pense
développement durable est en fait très
attention donc on arrose juste mesure ce
qu'il faut pour pour que le parcours
soit complètement jouable selon les
normes de ce type de tournoi et la météo
qui induit aussi des adaptations par
rapport au public la fréquentation est
toujours importante
oui il faut aussi prévoir pour le oui
oui les pré-ventes de billets cette
année sont extrêmement encourageants à
peu près 20% de plus que les autres
années donc ça c'est plutôt on ne voit
rien et sur combien de spectateurs
on aimerait bien en avoir dix mille par
jour s'ils ont fini la semaine à 30000
49 serait très bien avec la chaleur
ils viendront oui c'est noir dans un
petit peu quand même oui je pense
on a un recommandé de l'eau bien sûr
dans nos réunions de préparation
aujourd'hui hier on a pensé vraiment à
cette canicule et à la sécurité aussi
des spectateurs notamment aussi à
incendie on n'est pas à l'abri de deyris
donc une décision a été prise au niveau
de la cigarette mais il ya plein d'eau
et il ya des points où les gens pourront
se rassembler pour acheter ou se
rafraîchir un petit peu parce que les
températures devraient encore être
élevés tout au long de cette compétition
même si un petit peu plus qui est
attendu pourquoi pas des orages et là
aussi c'est toujours un moment délicat
si c'est demain serait parfait si c'est
entre 20 heures ce soir et quatre heures
demain matin c'est encore mieux comme ça
la compétition se déroulera
tranquillement du côté des golfeurs
peut-être à présent qu'est ce qui va
changer avec peut-être les modifications
que vous avez apporté par rapport aux
autres années même si le parcours reste
aux news ou moins semblables alors et
puis par rapport à la température et aux
chaleurs aussi parce que ça doit pas se
jouer pareil aussi non exactement
exactement il y a effectivement une
différence que les joueurs ont remarqué
le parcours est remarquable
ils le font en savoie on a quelques 10
sur 10 sur la préparation par contre il
remarque une différence dans ce qu'on
appelle le set up c'est à dire la façon
à laquelle on visualise le parcours il
ya des travaux qui ont été amenées par
notre super intendant alexandre
alejandro rees et son équipe cet hiver
on a enlevé beaucoup de 800 pour la
visibilité des joueurs en préparation
2018 aussi pour la ryder cup et voilà
mais il ya moins de refree à -2 aux
herbes cette année à cause de la
sécheresse dans les deux dernières mois
on a eu 4 mm de pluie depuis c'est une
côté compétition le nord-irlandais mec
d'aurélie peu il peut réaliser le triplé
c'est envisageable
bon pour le public et pour l'excitation
veut à vainqueur français
ça on va le dire on va pas s'en priver
par contre effectivement pour l'histoire
de l'open de france ce serait ce serait
sympa et les français ont de bonnes
chances justement le français un record
déjà il ya encore avant ton nom il ya 29
français qui vont prendre le départ
c'est du jamais vu
les conseils que vous pourriez donner
avant de s'élancer sur le parcours pour
les conversations c'est un drôle et
beaucoup d'eau et surtout amusez-vous où
on a parlé de la fréquentation également
est ce qu'on peut y voir là avec cette
hausse des réservations pour venir y
assister
une réussite de votre volonté de
démocratiser le golf aussi d'en faire un
sport accessible à tous et tout cela en
prévision de la ryder cup bien sûr en
2018 oui je pense
on a plusieurs actions sur sur la
communauté d'agglomération où on se
situe pour effectivement faire connaître
ce qu'on est en train d'essayer de faire
faire connaître ce sport qui a une inter
généralités génération par donc aucun
autre sport 1 un grand-père de 91 ans
peut jouer avec son petit fils ou sa
petite fille de 8 ans il ya pas beaucoup
de sport qu'ils peuvent proposer ça et
effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison en est dans une démarche de de
démocratisation parce que le golf est
moins cher que ce qu' il est moins cher
que parfois d'autres le golf pardon
national et est ouvert au public
oui on d'années j'ai pas uniquement pour
les professionnels au moment dé nos
éditions nous avons trois parcours on a
un parcours pour les débutants un centre
d'entraînement et d'accueil qui
s'appelle l'oise les qui est un site
fantastique qui vient d'être rénovée
d'ailleurs pour un meilleur accueil pour
tout client et après on peut suivre le
cheminement d'un golfeur en allant sur
une autre autre parcours avant de
devenir champion sur l'albatros ça coûte
combien on disait c'est pas si cher que
ça partir de 49 45 euros par mois on
peut s'équiper sur 12 - s'équiper avoir
des cours qui vont permettre à un joueur
d'apprendre
règle et puis taper dans la balle
correctement et jouer sur le parcours
qui dit mieux et pour découvrir le haut
niveau ce sera à partir de demain du 2
au 5 juillet 99e édition de cet open de
france de golf on va s'attarder là
présent pour conclure cet entretien sur
la ryder cup c'est cette compétition
entre les meilleurs américains et le
meilleur européen qui se déroule tous
les deux ans en alternance sur sur les
continents et 2018 ce sera à saint
quentin en yvelines donc en france un
comité de pilotage
elle vient de se tenir avec le ministre
des sports hier ça s'est passé comment
écouter les visites dans les clous
absolument on est dans les clous des
objectifs de la réunion c'était de bien
redire les engagements de la france
vis-à-vis des détenteurs de droits
qu'ils ont pris dr hop avec l'état qui
vient en aide avec cette organisation
je pense quand il faut le répéter c'est
le troisième événement mondial médiatisé
derrière jeux olympiques la coupe du
monde de foot et puis c'est un événement
golfique
on le connaît peu en france mais ça
vient ici lui encourt 52 en yvelines à
côté de chez nous normalement 2018 c'est
70000 spectateurs chaque jour c'est ça
tout dérape de françois c'est ça c'est
qu'on va remplir le stade de france ce
cinq jours de suite il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'artistes qu'ils font
maintenant temps qu'il faut des
infrastructures là aussi tous préparés
par goût est tout à fait nouvelle
il faut pas exactement mais je pense que
la plupart des des guest devant être
plutôt envers sa région parisienne et
puis les hôtels du coin vont être très
très très prisé c'est clair au niveau
des transports n'y a pas d'inquiétude à
avoir parce que il sera interdit pour le
grand public de venir jusqu'au parcours
donc jusqu'à nous ici à guyancourt en
voiture ce sera des parkings relais qui
sont qui vont de leur côté de versailles
ou plutôt vers ma si tout ça ce sera
pour 2018 il vous reste encore deux ans
et encore cette édition plus deux
éditions derrière pour se préparer avec
une semaine à l'open national c'est
toujours une petite répétition justement
oui oui je pense qu'on es ont testé un
peu des choses pendant sept exactement
exactement en teste des choses il faut
pas oublier cette année on va engager
des travaux importants pour préparer le
site aussi pour accueillir deux plus
importants infrastructures pour 2018
donc oui on est on est vigilants mais on
est créatif et on teste des choses et
tout va bien
il ya 2024 après les jeux olympiques
pourquoi pas vous avez déjà passé mais
avec plaisir à partir de demain la ryder
cup 2018 et puis après on a le temps de
parler de 1024
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau donc
demain au golf pour la compétition puis
nous en parlons bien sûr dans cette
édition a dès demain 18h en direct vie
locale pour poursuivre à présent une
salle des festivités au trait d'union
inauguré à magny les hameaux une salle
réservée en priorité aux particuliers
manie quoi mais pas uniquement les
habitants des autres communes peuvent
aussi y ont bénéficié catherine château
pour les précisions une salle des fêtes
pour les particuliers également les
associations les entreprises
c'est dorénavant une offre proposée par
la ville de magny les hameaux qui a
inauguré sa selle des festivités baptisé
au trait d'union
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une salle avant
qui a été
démoli donc ça manque quelques belles
salles
c'est une demande depuis des années des
habitants de la commune on a mis
longtemps à faire cette construction
c'est un projet qui date aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que très régulièrement nous
avions cette demande ont loué quelques
salles sur la commune mais qui étaient
des restaurants scolaires donc ce
n'était pas forcément très adapté
exemple de tarif de location 600 euros
pour un samedi soir si vous êtes même
quoi 1000 euros pour un week-end complet
des tarifs seront également pratiquées
en semaine et en journée la salle permet
d'accueillir soit 200 personnes debout
ou 160 10 à 6 elle a été construite tout
en bois une résine rouge recouvre le sol
on a fait le choix de faire une
construction en bois nnous par son le
côté écologique du matériau de
la rapidité de construction même si le
bâtiment ce chantier a pris un peu de
temps à vivre et et aussi pour répondre
un peu aux matériaux du site le parc
bruno le parc des sports qui est un
espace assez ouvert et c'est végétale de
matériaux aussi a des vertus thermique
environnemental c'est un matériau qui
somme toute est incessant en plus on a
fait le choix de le ces brutes et de ne
pas traiter
on est tous conscients de ce bâtiment va
vivre ouvert griser
se griser de façon différente ont
fonctionné face à des expositions coût
de la réalisation dont le chantier a
duré deux ans estimé à 1,7 million
d'euros
un surcoût de 7 % raison notamment de
malfaçons un financement à hauteur de
750 mille euros par des emprunts et
650000 euros par le foll concours de la
casse qui les réservations sont ouvertes
depuis ce lundi
ouverture officielle au 1er septembre
culture télévision le gecko crous est un
trio de danseurs hip hop et de street
dance et ils sont originaires de saint
quentin en yvelines ils vivent en ce
moment laventure got to dance c est
diffusée sur la tnt sur tmc
anna jimenez et william elles les ont
rencontrés quelques crous et un groupe
qu'on a monté en septembre maintenant
c'est ça les gars septembre dernier et
voilà c'est parti d'une idée commune
c'était un peu de signer tous les trois
puisque à la base on était vraiment 3 3
potes dans la vie et on a commencé en
publiant des vidéos sur internet et tout
est parti de là cette émission nous aura
permis de rencontrer beaucoup de
danseurs du milieu ça ça a été un point
très bénéfique pour nous trois et en
dehors de ça elle nous aura apporté une
certaine visibilité
malgré tout les groupes qui ont pu
passer mais c'est vrai qu'on est content
de ça et on espère que ça va continuer
là il ya eu le premier prime qui a été
diffusé on verra pour la suite mais pour
l'instant voilà ce que nous ont rapporté
les missions
je dirais que c'est avant tout enfin pas
avant tout mais principalement du pôle
commercial en importe que tu touches
trip jazz on va dire quelques touches
d'humour un peu de relais dans le corps
et graphie mais c'est avant tout une
époque bien sûr je pense que ce style il
nous parle de par notre formation
commune à tous les trois on peut dire
merci à hiddink l association s'est
rencontré on a énormément appris
l'association de voisins-le-bretonneux
qui est dirigé par olaf cybit et à dino
art et voilà ils nous ont insufflé en
fait ce goût de la chorégraphie de la
propreté de la rigueur et je pense que
ceci nous vient nous vient cette
association dollars siby a été dans les
blacks blancs beurs à l'époque et donc
il
il a ramené ce côté hip hop à voisins et
aussi sur la commune de maurepas si on
les voyants réussir dans ce métier même
si c'était dur même si c'était compliqué
ils nous ont donné envie nous ont
poussés ils ont gueulé dessus bien sûr
et à force on y prend goût et ça donne
envie de faire de faire de même
ma patience que nous sert à 3 ans fait
un gecko qui vient du petit lézard et
c'est un symbole de persévérance et dans
la danse un milieu qui est très dur donc
il en faut de la persévérance et et nous
on a trouvé que ça nous caractérise
c'est bien ou trois c'est venu d'un
stage de danse en fait qu'on fait tous
les étés ensemble et c'est un prof qui
avait beaucoup de charisme qui nous a
beaucoup marqués qui nous parlait de ça
de cette histoire et on s'est dit
pourquoi pas reprendre un peu ce symbole
et est du coup en faire le symbole de
notre coup le but ouais je pense que ce
serait de réussir à faire de la danse
notre métier est pour nous le rêve c'est
c'est d'emmener ce trio le plus loin
possible d'une façon professionnelle en
fait et voilà on espère que ça va
marcher sinon on a tous fait des études
au cas où ça marche pas pour reprendre
et on va tout faire pour que ça marche
mais mais voilà on a préféré garder un
plan b au cas où suivez nous sur got to
dance tmc sur la page facebook
gecko crew way et sur twitter et ouais
et sur un stade suivez nous sur les
réseaux sociaux et on vous dis à très
bientôt
bonne chance pour la suite de la
compétition c'est la fin de ce journal
je vous retrouve demain aux horaires
habituels pour un nouveau point sur
l'actualité locale très belle soirée